okay I don't know what's going on but
there's someone in my house right now
I've got in the closet I can't figure it
out but there's someone coming in my
house and I keep hearing noises and
banging and screaming and all this kind
of stuff and I don't know what's going
on it's really scared me I don't got
over his name I don't know what's
happening Silent House stars Elizabeth
Olsen and it's kind of a gimmick movie I
mean you could call it that it's a movie
made to look as if it's all done in one
take which is a very impressive feat and
the film actually pulls it off fairly
well so I was kind of interested in
seeing with the American remake adieu
plus I did like elizabeth Olsen a lot in
Martha Marcy May Marlene and she is very
attractive in fact she's so good-looking
in this movie it was like if you feel
guilty for being attracted to the Olsen
twins you can kind of be okay with being
attracted Elizabeth also because even
though she looks very similar she
actually has quite a bit of acting
talent not to miss the Olsen twins the
Olsen twins no childhood full house
that's that's good oh good this movie is
about basically is a girl is alone in a
house and her father is there in her
uncle and she starts to hear these
banging noises downstairs and then she
finds her father her father's hurt
someone's in the house trying to kill
her basically and the whole movie is
pretty much her trying to hide
throughout this house but the thing is
it's all made to look like it's done in
one shot and yes you could tell there's
a few cuts throughout the movie but
really not that many which is very
impressive throughout the majority of
this movie I was pretty scared actually
and you know how like when a movie does
like a long sequence where like a
character is just like walking through
the hallways or through the forest and
the cameras following her and you're
thinking that anything could jump out at
any second in most horror films there's
almost always a sequence like that this
movie is basically like that throughout
the entire run time elizabeth Olsen was
great in the movie her performance was
magnetic she gave such a great
performance in this movie you might at
times think maybe she was going a little
bit too over the top of the crime and
that may be true but I really think she
was great in this movie and she is not
hard to look at I will say that as well
okay so problems I have in the movie I
actually have a major problem with this
movie and I can't really get into it
without spoiling it but I'll just say
that aspects of
finale kind of messed things up for me
the way the film concluded it just did
not work for me at all actually I was
thinking like an a-minus as the movie
progressed I was really getting into it
that ending took the movie all the way
down to a B so I'm gonna give Silent
House of B it's a fun horror film it has
a great performance by Elizabeth Olsen
but the way the film decides to end just
kind of ruined a lot of stuff for me but
I can't deny the fact that I enjoyed the
previous 90 minutes of the film I'd like
to know what's your favorite low-budget
horror film because I love low-budget
horror when it's done really well
there's something really exhilarating
about seeing a horror film and you know
that they were just like reaching into
their pockets to try to finish the movie
what's your favorite horror film like
that thanks very much for watching guys
and until next time if you like this
review you can subscribe to my channel
and get stuck my knives